though cosby's criminal conviction
reflects a dramatic shift in society's
view of sexual assault
many of his accusers and their
supporters acknowledged the impact of
the me2 movement on Cosby's retrial the
me to a movement has arrived'
and as well and is living in Montgomery
County throughout this nation and
throughout this world
this jury has shown that the me to what
the me to movement has saying is that
women are worthy of being believed we
are now part of the tsunami of women's
power and justice we are not shutting up
and we're not going away get over it
Cosby was convicted of three counts of
aggravated indecent assault he could get
up to ten years in prison for each of
those counts Cosby's lawyers say they
will appeal CBS News contributor Jody
Kanter is an investigative reporter for
The New York Times she co-wrote the
first story reporting sexual assault
allegations against Harvey Weinstein The
Times just want two Pulitzer Prize for
Jody's extensive reporting which
contributed to a worldwide reckoning of
sexual harassment and assault
Jody good morning it's good to see you
it's good to have you at the table and
once again this morning we wake up to
news that Tom Brokaw is now included in
the me2 movement and I'm wondering I
don't think any of us take any joy or
pleasure of seeing this happen to
anybody but I wonder how you're feeling
is someone who really started a me-too
movement with what is happening do you
feel a pride about it or ownership about
it because I certainly think that it has
changed the game and certainly in the
Bill Cosby trial as well I certainly
don't feel ownership because so many
people contributed to this most
importantly the women who have come
forward over the years I think part of
what was both emotional and significant
about yesterday is that so many people
thought this would never happen but so
many women had given up hope essentially
even gone all red who was here Jody
excuse me for interrupting said she was
surprised by the verdict exactly exactly
so when it finally came it felt like
whoa did something just change was this
a marker in the history of women being
believed and remember that this is such
a long-running drama some of these women
came forward years and
years ago so the sense of justice
delayed and then finally delivered was
very profound yet Jody while the walls
are falling and this is a total change
you still here in the Cosby trial and
other places people say well why did
they take so long and saying a lot of
the things that we're bricks in that
original wall how much of how much has
really changed or do you still see parts
of the culture or maybe outside of the
limelight where things are not changing
at all well you know the tactics that
Cosby's lawyers used against andrea
constand were fascinating because we saw
that even in 2017 a woman who comes
forward can be attacked as a con artist
somebody who is just seeking money and
yet at the same time we know that that
tactic failed I think the essential
truth is that it is still really really
really hard for women to come forward
and it's gonna take us years to break
down those barriers I mean that what was
different about this trial too is that
they allowed other witnesses to come in
and testify and Cosby's attorneys
attacked them like they attacked and Roy
Cohn stabbed talking about Janice
Dickinson past sexual history I mean
really personal attacks do you think
they backfired
oh they certainly backfired we can see
from the verdict but it that question of
numbers I think also gets to what we've
all experienced in the last couple of
months which is you know at the paper we
often say it's the pattern it's the
pattern it's the pattern it was the
pattern with Weinstein the profound
reporting experience of hearing these
women from all over the world different
ages different backgrounds different
eras and yet they had such similar
allegations against Harvey Weinstein and
that's what happened in the Cosby case
as well but it's also happening on a
wider level because so many women who
are not in the spotlight also have these
similar stories and so I think we're
still asking the question of how can it
be that women all over the country in
the world
she profoundly experienced these similar
things and yet we never understood this
pattern fully until now well we've
talked about that and this is because
it's systemic and it's pervasive how
we've truly addressed the systemic and
systematic part of this you know the the
the the things that happen in companies
that allow this to happen yes and part
of what was fascinating a
the Baroque a story by Sarah Ellison of
The Washington Post which also had some
fresh allegations about Matt Lauer is
that she used those allegations to
really drive home a bigger point of
eight about HR and to ask the question
what would need to happen with human
resources departments to make women
actually feel safe coming forward in the
workplace
the first answer of course is that there
has to be a guarantee that there will be
no retaliation retaliation can almost be
as bad as the original action because
you know the saying it's not the crime
it's the cover-up retaliation says
something happened to you and I'm not
gonna listen I'm gonna use my power to
silence you instead of to deal with the
problem we should note that we reached
out to NBC for comment and they have
we've not heard back yet from them what
interests you what's the question you're
trying to answer now in the work that
you're doing with respect to this well
thank you for asking Megan Julie my
partner and I are working on a book and
it's about the Weinstein case but it's
also about the larger questions of this
pattern and how we address them as Nora
said what we're looking at here is
systemic this is actually not about
individual perpetrators what we see with
the secret settlements that prevent
victims from coming forward and warming
warning other people the HR failures
weak laws that fail to adequately
protect women what we see is that this
is really about fundamentally about a
system that does not work for women that
perpetuates these acts often that keeps
the victims from being able to tell
their stories are getting healed and so
how do we actually change that whole
system it's also a different time now
and I think some in some cases many men
just haven't gotten the memo that now
it's now 2018 and what may have been
acceptable or overlooked back then is no
longer going to fly today well and also
we're just not done with the old stories
right I mean yesterday shows that were
not done with the Cosby stories we're
not done with the NBC stories there are
we're still getting phone calls all the
time there's still a lot of processing
to be done on what even what even the
current generation of women has faced in
the workplace Jodie Cantor always going
to have you here thank you thank you